الحمد
لله
next شيخ واثق
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله حمدا يوافي
نعمه ويكافئ مزيده ويدفع عنا بلاءه
ونقمه لك الحمد يا ربنا حتى ترضى ولا حول
ولا قوه الا بالله العلي
العظيم واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له له الملك وله الحمد
يحيي ويميت وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان سيدنا وعظيمنا وحبيبنا
وقائدنا وشفيعنا محمدا عبده
ورسوله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله الطيبين
واصحابه اجمعين ومن سار على نهجهم الى يوم
الدين السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
ومه
وبر
شا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
وي السلام ورحمه الله
وبركاته ما شاء
الله
ابتداء من لا يشكر الناس لا يشكر الله
تعالى الله والله تعالى يقول ولان شكرتم
لازيدنكم
شر
فشكرا
جزيل
اقدمه للاخت
الكريمه
مديره الاخت
كما واشكر الاخوه في
البورد على دعمهم لنا
في كذلك اشكر
كل الاخوه والاخوات
والله سبحانه وتعالى هو اعلم
باسمائهم واشكر كل الاباء
والامهات على جلب اولادهم الى الس
وانا ابشركم ابشر الاباء والامهات الذين
جلبوا اولادهم الى سكول
بتاج من نور على رؤوسهم يوم القيا
[Silence]
لانه من علم اولاده حفظ القران الكريم
وتلاوه القران الكريم كما جاء في الحديث
البس الله والديه تاجا من نور يوم
القيامه البسه الله تاج يوم الق
[Silence]
فهذا اخواني يا اخواني واخواتي هذا رصيد
لكم يوم القيامه
والنبي صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه وسلم
يقول محد ى الله عليه
وسلم علموا اولادكم
القران وعلموهم
الادب وعلموهم حب النبي وال
بيته محد مح
والنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول
خيركم من تعلم القران
وعلمه محمدى الله عليه
وسلم سيدنا الامام علي رضي الله تعالى عنه
وكرم الله وجه
امامي طالب
حفظت القران خم
خمر
يعني البارحه يعني ثلاث ايام
كنت
تساس وزرت عدد من المدارس
والمساجد وما شاء الله
وجدت عدد كبير من الاولاد يعني من عمر عش
سنوات الى 17 سنه يحفظون القران كله ما
شاء الله
والعجيب في ذلك اكثر الذين يحفظون القران
من هؤلاء هم من غير
العرب سبحان الله من باكستان والهند وبنج
طبعا من مصر ايض في كان حفظت قران واستمعت
الى هؤ
فذلك انا ادعوكم ادعو
الاباء ان تحثوا
اولادكم وهم
امانه على تعليم القران وحفظ القران وهم
امانه في اعناقكم
القر نحتاج
الى ان نتعلم طرقا في كيفيه تحبيب
الاسلام وتحبيب القران الى
[Silence]
اولادنا يعني شجع
او بطريقه من غير ضغط
عليه لانه وايضا ادعو يعني اخوات الذي
اللواتي او الاخوه الذين يمارسون تدريس
القران الكريم ادعوهم ان يكونوا رحماء
وان يستخدموا حب الولد والبنت عندما يعلم
ويحفظون القران الكريم
[Silence]
لانه اكيد
وبيت الاب والام والاخوه الكبار دور كبير
في حضانه الولد في تعليم القران او البنت
[Silence]
انا لا اريد ان اطيل عليكم لانه في عندنا
برنامج كبير للاولاد انا اريد ان اعطي
الفرصه للاولاد حتى يعرف الاباء والامهات
[Silence]
ثمره لا مثل ما ذكرت التر ع جزاه الله خير
يعني يوم واحد في الاسبوع لا
يك وليس ب المدرسين جزاهم الله
خريه فتابعوا اولادكم
بكيفيه كراه القران الكريم وحفظ
ولا تقصروا مع
اولادكم لان الله سبحانه وتعالى سبحانه
وتعالى
قفوهم انهم
مسول وكلكم راع وكلكم
مسؤول الحمدلله يعني كنا في
او الحمدلله في السكول وصل عدد الطلبه في
الس سكول الى
الحمدلله وصل
عدد الى 75
عملنا معهم وقرانا لهم القران وعلمهم
اللغه العربيه وعلمهم اداب
الاسلام عدد من قصص
الانبياء عليه الصلاه والسلامه واللام عدد
من الاحاديث عن النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام
ولك يا
اخواني اربطوا كلامي الاخير
لكم اربطوا انفسكم واولادكم
بالمسجد تعالوا مع اولادكم الى صلاه
الجمعه في عندنا برامج بعد صلاه المغرب كل
اثنين واربعاء
تفسير القران
الكريم ايض عندنا برنامج كل خميس فقط
للاخوات
لنساء كيفيه قراءه القران الكريم
مع الاخت ا جزاه الله
خيرمان الامهات يسجلون اسماه مع الاخت ام
ايهاب لهذا البرنامج برنامج جيد
جدا وقد بدان بحفظ سوره البقره ما شاء
الله
سبت
واحد لشرح احاديث النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم بعد صلاه
العشاء كذلك
عندنا حلقه
ذكر هذه حلقه الذكر جدا مهمه ان تعلمون
اولادكم وحلقه الذكر نعمل فيها الدعاء
والاستغفار بصوت جهري حتى تحفظوا
كي كيفيه الدعاء
[Silence]
بعد صلاه
العشاء تعالم
واكم الامر الاخير الحمد لله انا ابشركم
باننا قد بدانا
ببناء مسجد كبير في
توس الحمد
هذا المسجد سيكون على
ريفر وهذا المسجد فيه سيكون فيه مدرسه
لاولادكم فلذلك ترون الان المكان جدا ضيق
وبعضهم غير موجود انا قلتلكم عندنا
175 تلميذ
الحمد فلذلك ايض انا ادعوكم الى التبرع
الى في بناء المسجد
الجديد والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول من
بنى لله مسجدا بنى الله له بيتا في الجنه
محدى الله
علس بارك الله فيكم واشكركم كثيرا واني
داعم
فامنوا تقل انك انت السميع
العليم اميني امين وتب علينا يا مولانا
انك انت التواب
الرحيم اللهم ارحمنا بالقران
العظيم اللهم حفظنا منه يا رب
العالمين اللهم وارزقنا تلاوته اناء الليل
واطراف النهار لعلك ترضى امين اللهم اجعل
القران العظيم ربيع
قلوبنا ونور
صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا
وهمومنا اللهم ذكرنا ما نسينا منه يا
الله اللهم اجعله حجه لنا ولا تجعله حجه
علينا
يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام اللهم احفظ هذا المجتمع من كل
سوء وجنبهم الفتن ما ظهر منها وما بطن
اللهم احفظ اولاد المسلمين اللهم استر على
نساء المسلمين
الله ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا وذرياتنا قره
اعين واجعلنا للمتقين
اللهم فرج عن اخواننا المظلومين في كل
مكان اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في العراق
اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في سوريا اللهم
احقن دماء المسلمين في مصر وليبيا
وباكستان وافغانستان
وفي
فلسطين وفي كل مكان يا رب العالمين والف
بين قلوبهم ووحد صفوفهم يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين بارك الله فيك ربس